and this is where it gets real fun okay
what have we just
established right in case it wasn't fun
already addition and subtraction
addition and subtraction essentially
you are going to get and on your diagram
you've sort of already got this right
if you've got on the complex plane uh
one complex number here and then another
complex number over here
to add them means to sort of do one
after the other so i would end up
somewhere i guess over here you can sort
of
picture that imaginary parallelogram
right in fact imaginary is
exactly the right word for it so that's
what addition and subtraction does
multiplication by a real number
multiplication
[Music]
by some real number like three or two
and a half or one
or whatever it is that i've got there
right what was suggesting was it's an
idea of scale
right so if i've got some complex number
like so if i multiply it by some real
number that's
bigger than one you're going to end up
like we showed over here
like so there's a scaling factor going
on or of course i could
multiply something between naught and
one or i could even go in the opposite
direction if i multiply by a negative
now that's multiplication by a real
number
you already know because we covered at
the end of last lesson you have a bit of
an introduction
what happens if we multiply not by a
real number
but by an imaginary number like say i
what effect
did that have on the successes z1z2z3
what did we use
what geometric word can you use to
describe what's going on it's
it's anti-clockwise rotation
around the origin do you remember that
right let me say that again in fact it's
so important i'll write it
multiplication by an imaginary number
gives us anti-clockwise
rotation and it's not just anywhere like
it's not like if i
took this wiper marker and then i just
spun it on the spot right
i'm actually spinning it about the
origin do you guys remember back in year
seven
um rotation requires a point about which
you rotate
and the point about which we're rotating
is the origin
so we've got numbers like uh like this
or
this or this so this is what happens
when we multiply by a real number or
when we multiply by
an imaginary number but this topic is
not called
real numbers or imaginary numbers this
topic is called
complex numbers which means we want to
see what happens when we combine these
right so here's what i'd like you to do
you will shortly need a new
complex plane for this okay what i'd
like you to do is think of
a complex number any complex number you
like
but probably to make things nice for
yourself maybe choose some integer
coefficients for the real and imaginary
components okay and importantly this is
really really important
when you think of your own complex
number please think of a different one
to the people on either side of you i
want in fact everyone in the room to
have a different
complex number choose one write it down
um it'd be great if between you and the
people around you you had some positives
and some negatives as well
i've intentionally chosen just positive
stuff here just sort of easier to
visualize
but choose some stuff in the second
quadrant or the third or the fourth
come up with a complex number i'll give
you 10 seconds and do that and write it
down
just think of one look at the person
next to you make sure you haven't come
up with the same number
and then here's what i'd like you to do
i'm all of you together
we know what happens when you do these
in isolation but if we do them
simultaneously
i want you all to multiply your chosen
complex number
i'm just going to call it z because i'm
original like that maybe z one because
it's a specific complex number
go ahead and multiply it by
2 plus 2i i've chosen
that number specifically 2 plus 2 i do
it
with arithmetic and then i'd like you to
plot both of these numbers
your number that you chose and the
result that you get when you multiply
through by 2 plus 2i
plot those both onto an argand diagram
for me
okay do it nice and neatly your scale is
actually going to be very important here
so be accurate if you're a grid book you
have a bit of an advantage there but
once you've done that you've got a
result go ahead and compare to the
person next to you as well
and see what you can observe off you go
now i will admit i kind of threw a
little bit in the deep end by
letting you choose whatever number you
wanted but you know what yeah you're the
extension two class i reckon you can
handle being thrown in the deep end
i am however as i've done in the past
right i'm gonna ask
um one of you in particular because uh
you chose an interesting number
that we're all gonna do together so
underneath where you've done yours
i'd like you to follow with me smart's
example
okay and then we're gonna have a look at
this one in a second too
samantha you chose as your original
complex number
what 2i alright so i'm going to place
and i'd love you to place as well
to i here on the imaginary
axis i shouldn't eaten this up you
should always yeah draw a new one
i mean if your complex numbers are
sufficiently far away from where smarts
put his
maybe you can fit on the same one but
otherwise draw a new one it's fine
um by the way it is always important and
i've been a bit slack on this that you
do
state like this is a complex plane so
i've got real and imaginary axis it's
not
x and y which are two real numbers and
so on okay so i've got two i here
right now when you go ahead and you
multiply
this by two plus two i
maybe maybe smile just did it because
the arithmetic is nice and easy do you
want to go ahead and tell us what the
answer is
go ahead yeah yeah minus four
four i minus four are you happy with
that
minus four plus four there's four i
4i right then when i do this part
it'll be minus 4
hold on think about this right this is
plus 4i squared
right right careful it's just
simplification but
2 times 2 gives you 4. i times i gives
you i
squared but we know that by definition i
squared is
negative 1 so he's actually done an
extra line of working that's fine okay
so 4i minus 4 we tend to write the
number in a different order even though
we generally like
in real numbers we like subtraction to
come next
we've so far been writing it in what
order real part first
which in this case is negative 4 and
then the imaginary part like so
okay um that helps us as well especially
we're doing this stuff on the complex
plane
because you can think of them as sort of
an x coordinate and a y coordinate so go
ahead
and let's put this onto our diagram
okay now hopefully as you stare at your
diagram and stare at this one
if you have not already this interval
that we draw from our complex number
to the origin is going to clarify what
change is happening
right so go ahead and put both of those
on
for every single one of us and for this
one here and the one on screen
right what's going on is that there's a
combination of these two things
happening
because we're multiplying by a real
number and by an imaginary number
and so therefore is there a change
in scale to the original number we
supplied
answer yes because i chose what we were
all multiplying by
all of the complex numbers that you
ended up with were
further away from the origin than you
started with right
that's the first thing so scale is
happening there's also
rotation happening now i've chosen um
smart number particularly because
the actual kind of rotation is
particularly obvious
have a look here with me right this uh
triangle that i'm just sort of putting
onto here
right here here and here it's not just
any triangle it's not a random triangle
what kind of triangle is it it's right
angle is the first thing i heard what
else can you tell me about it
it's also isosceles because it's
negative 4
plus 4i yes so this side and this side
are the same
as a consequence you can tell me what
all the angles
in this triangle are being that it's
right angled and isosceles
we're going to have we've already got
radians don't we yes we've got radians
okay so we've got pi on 2
over here in the corner what do we got
for our other angles
pi on 4 because everything has to add up
to pi
pi on 4 pi on 4.
what this tells us is that this angle
in here the one between your complex
number
and the new one we got when multiplying
it had an
anti-clockwise rotation it was about the
origin
but it wasn't the right angle that you
saw in the first distance last week
right in this case it's
pi on four have a look at your diagram
if you did it
accurately you should be getting this
exact same thing there's a scale
and there's also this rotation of pi on
four
how come now to answer the how come
we're really close to just sort of
letting you go on your exercise now but
i need a bit more space
we need to get a better handle on what
kind of scale
is going on we know that there is
lengthening happening enlargement i
guess to use that word
but um how much bigger is it how much
further away
is your new complex number from the
origin
compared to the new one right or the old
one from the new one right
what's the difference in other words in
the scale factor from here
to here how would we work that out
how would we work out how much we've
scaled by like if i didn't say to you
and i think i just heard half the answer
if i didn't say to you
here's the number it's three so you end
up
three times further away someone want to
help me out working out
how do i calculate that scale factor
pi so i said it again pythagoras okay so
i've got
i've just got this writing triangle here
identified before
i know what the two shorter sides are
they're four and four so therefore
what's the long side
it's the square root of four squared
plus four squared right
we're extension two we can do
pythagoras's theorem yes okay last i
checked
that was the square root of 16 plus 16
32. can you write that any simpler
please tell me you can write that square
root of 32 what what factor can you pull
out
you can take out uh 16 or i should say
the square root of 16
right so that means you're gonna have uh
four root
two as the distance outside there happy
what about this distance that's just two
right because by definition you've gone
two units upwards so how much
further away is that what factor is it
it's yeah it's it's two root two or two
times
further away do you agree here we were
three times further away because we
multiply by three
where's this come from and for that
matter where'd this come from this pi
on four pi on four and two root two what
do they have to do
with well this is the number i supplied
you right
okay last thing to put onto your complex
lane i promise
2 2i can you fit it onto this argan
diagram i think it should be on my
diagram anyway
it's going to be about here
2 plus 2i that's where i place it okay
can anyone tell me what is the
significance
of pi on 4 the angle
and 2 root 2 the distance
what is the significance of these to
this
can you see it i would say the angle is
easier to spot than the length but
go ahead i'll be happy to start an
eyeball
yeah go ahead try one which one do you
want to do do you want to talk about the
angle the length
yeah okay tell me about the length two
or two
two is the length of the vector
representing two plus two i okay so
interesting answer so you're introducing
some language which
um as a student who did not take physics
in year 11 or 12
i'm going to hold off on for a second
the word vector we will come to believe
me
we will come to that in this course
shortly but for now
i think what you're referring to is is
this length here right
this is the thing we're talking about
and that length there you can go ahead
and work it out by pythagoras just like
we worked out this one
it's going to be 2 root 2. is that okay
two
two is the length from the origin to
here what about pi on four
pi on four where is that yeah go ahead
cos of pi on 4
or sine of find 4 is that what i heard
you say yeah
so i really love that your brain went
here right because
it's true there's like the square roots
of two
and this pi and four business should
make your like trigonometry sense tingle
right because both of these are one on
root two okay i'm going to shove that
idea for a second because
it actually is going to take me some
work to illustrate there is a connection
by the way that's not accidental
let me see if i can get to you to where
this is right remember we drew this
right angle triangle over here before
and we notice the angle is beside it
well there's a right angle triangle that
goes with this guy too right
it's here
see that one right there do you see
where pine4 is
here that's the angle that i'm
interested in it's the angle from the
real axis and then i rotate sorry i
rubbed it off
anti-clockwise you come to here and
where's two root two it's it's this
length
here now this is actually something
which
in the syllabus comes a little bit later
along with some of the other language
that we're referring to right
but you're doing these operations and we
really badly mrs lee's and i want you to
know
visually what does any of this mean
i'd love you to after after you have a
go at the exercise we're about to set
you right
go back to 1a go back to the exercise we
did we worked on all of last week
you did a whole bunch of addition and
subtraction and multiplication
even division which we haven't quite
touched this lesson
what does it all mean visually well
now we have a sense sort of for what
multiplication does
it rotates and it also scales
right and we're going to knuckle down
into we need some more tools to
understand what's going on here
to get some more precision but we want
you to see what was happening okay